>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION.
STEVE SCALISE WAS SHOT A YEAR
AND FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL,
PAM BONDI.
YOU WENT TO SEE THE "MR. ROGERS"
MOVIE.
>> IT'S A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
>> Sean: TELL PEOPLE HOW BAD IT
WAS.
THEY'RE CALLING YOU EVERY NAME
IN THE BOOK.
YOU HAD YOUR BECOME WITH YOU.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: WHAT DID THEY SAY TO
HIM?
>> OH, WE GET THERE.
WE'RE WAITING IN LINE TO GET
TICKETS.
YOU KNOW A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
MR. ROGERS.
THIS WOMAN STARTS TELLING ME
THAT I'M RIPPING BABIES OUT OF
THE PETER FONDA LINE ABOUT
MELANIA.
I SAID I'M GLAD YOU'RE VIDEOING
ME.
LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU.
I NEVER AGREED FROM SEPARATING
THE BABIES FROM THEIR MOTHERS.
I'M GLAD THE PRESIDENT SIGNED
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
I SAID, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
CONGRESSIONAL ISSUE.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHO THEIR
CONGRESSMEN WERE.
SO WHEN THEY REALIZED THAT
>> THEY WERE USING THE P WORD,
THE A WORD, THE F WORLD.
>> COME ON, AREN'T YOU GOING TO
PROTECT HER?
>> Sean: WHAT THEY CALLING HIM
TO YOUR GIRLFRIEND?
>> YES.
>> Sean: IF HE WOULD HAVE
RESPONDED, HE GETS ARRESTED.
>> THAT'S HOW I STOPPED HIM.
THERE WERE TWO MORE ALTERCATIONS
AFTER THAT, AFTER I THOUGHT THEY
WERE GONE.
>> Sean: AND BIG GUYS, TOO.
>> BLOCKED ME FROM WALKING IN.
>> Sean: WHY ARE YOU -- IF
SOMEBODY GETS IN YOUR GRILL LIKE
THAT, IS THAT NOT -- IT'S AN
FROM LEAVING.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY WHAT THEY WANTED.
I WASN'T GOING TO GIVE THE FIVE
MINUTES OF FAME.
>> Sean: WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS
TO YOU?
SARAH SANDERS, SECRETARY NIELSEN
AND CHILDREN?
WE'RE GOING AFTER BARON, THE
4-YEAR-OLD GRANDDAUGHTER OF
IVANKA.
TOUGH GUYS.
I'M AVAILABLE.
COME AFTER ME.
FOLLOW ME.
I'LL HANDLE IT.
>> THAT'S IT.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
SO THEN THEY HAD TWO HOURS WHILE
I WAS IN THE MOVIE.
>> Sean: AND THEY GATHERED MORE
PEOPLE.
>> OF COURSE.
THAT IS THE VIDEO AFTER THE
FACT.
THE POLICE SAID WE'RE GOING TOO
TAKE YOU OUT THE BACK DOOR.
I SAID NO WAY.
I'M WALKING OUT THE DOOR I CAME
IN.
THEY'RE NOT GOING BULLY ME.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN, GREAT PLAY
AT SECOND BASE.
THAT WAS AN UNBELIEVABLE PLAY.
YOU WERE IN -- THE FIRST PLAY OF
THE GAME.
I WATCHED YOUR PIECE WITH BUDDY
PETER DOOCY.
BASICALLY IN ONE FOOT.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YEAH, THE LEFT FOOT STILL HAS
A LOT OF NERVE DAMAGE.
AS WEEK.
>> Sean: HERE'S MY QUESTION.
DO YOU CONNECT THEIR -- WHAT YOU
SAW WITH SECRETARY NIELSON AND
WHAT HAPPENED TO SARAH, WHAT
HAPPENED TO PAM AND THE THINGS
THAT ARE BEING SAID ABOUT
BLOWING UP A WHITE HOUSE AND THE
THINGS SAID ABOUT BARON TRUMP
AND THE PRESIDENT'S
GRANDDAUGHTER, DO YOU THINK
RESULT IN SOMEBODY GETTING
SEVERELY INJURED OR MAYBE EVEN
KILLED?
>> SEAN, CLEARLY THEY'RE
INCITEFUL.
I'VE SEEN HOW THAT KIND OF
INCITEFUL LANGUAGE CAN LEAD TO
SOMETHING DANGEROUS.
THERE'S FINE LINES TO CROSS.
WE'RE A NATION THAT WAS BUILT ON
THIS GREAT IDEA THAT YOU CAN
DISAGREE WITH PEOPLE.
>> Sean: IS MAXINE WATERS AND
TRUMP IN GAS STATIONS AND
RESTAURANTS, CONFRONT THEM,
EXCEPT CREATE A SITUATION THAT
IS GOING TO BLOW?
>> I THINK IT CROSSES THE LINE,
SEAN.
AGAIN, THIS IS ABOUT CIVILITY.
YOU SHOULD GO IN ONE OF -- WIN
YOUR IDEAS IN A DEBATE OF PUBLIC
OPINION.
IF YOU'RE IDEAS ARE WORSE, WHICH
I THINK CONSERVATIVE IDEAS WIN
AND VIOLENCE.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK IT CROSSES
THE LINE.
>> Sean: YOU'RE LUCKY TO BE
ALIVE TODAY.
TO THINK THAT TWO CAPITOL HILL
POLICE OFFICERS WALKED IN A WIDE
OPEN FIELD WITH PISTOLS AGAINST
A RIFLE, THAT WAS BASICALLY A
>> THE MIRACLES OF GOD.
GOD PERFORMS REAL MIRACLES.
WE SHOULDN'T GET TO THIS.
WE DIDN'T TOLERATE IT UNDER
OBAMA.
YOU AND I AND SO MANY OTHERS
DIDN'T AGREE WITH HIS POLICIES.
BUT WE NEVER CONDONED THIS
ACTION.
>> Sean: DO YOU AGREE WITH ME
THIS ISN'T A THEIR LOSING, THEY
LOST, THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SUCCESSFUL, HIS FOREIGN POLICY
AND THE FACT THAT MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT, THE GREAT HOPE IS
CRUMBLING, IS THAT WHAT IS
CAUSING THIS?
THE ELECTION PENDING?
>> PEOPLE ARE SO ANGRY THE
PRESIDENT IS SUCCEEDING AND THE
COUNTRY IS THRIVING AND THEY'RE
LASHING OUT AT THE EXPEND OF --
I CAN TAKE CARE OF MYSELF BUT AT
THE EXPENSE OF THESE PEOPLE IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> Sean: I THOUGHT THEY CARED
ABOUT WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND HAD
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS.
THE REASON I RAN THE HISTORY
LESSON IS BECAUSE THEY DO IT
EVERY TWO AND FOUR YEARS.
IT'S THEIR ONLY PLAYBOOK.
SOMEBODY WILL GET KILLED.
MARK MY WORDS, I PRAY TO GOD I'M
WRONG.
THIS IS GETTING SCARY.